I'd like to talk a little bit now about
the the thrust and the observation is
that I've noticed from these people
taking their teachers
certification
they do the sixth of Burnley but then it
becomes
so they they've come down
and they it's it just becomes a poem
so what I suggest you do is just work on
the thrusting part so
again I've timed this
foot
what you don't want to do is the pumping
action you don't want to go
okay I want to soften
soften
and the reason you soften
is to give you
some feeling some energy some timing
sofa
hey
and add some energy feeling sulfur hey
it's gonna start building it everybody
wants to get there in a hurry but the
the thing to do is
soft
not too much movement
okay and then speed up as you feel
better
on the surface of area it's just on the
other side but we'll start
we started the canop here
if you don't move the king
it's in your hands and whatever
that hand turns naturally this head
turns naturally there don't try and
twist it anymore just turn it naturally
okay and that's enough people ask this
question at times so
if you're in this
so now soften again
this is just an exercise okay you're
building up your thrusting so
it comes down
hey
the game don't turn this back the body
the body pushes it
forward
not too much turning here like this
okay
come here
and keep it
inside the body
inside the body and insert the body
okay you build slowly
and
in time every little rush so you've got
to
stop your ego
take some breaths slow it down and
um
the slower the better because you'll
feared it and then that will really
build strength timing
and you'll get so much of a richness out
of this sort of training
okay
thank you for your time